untamed that's new oh wow we're supposed
to shoot that I'm supposed to ignore
that you think so yeah it's not going to
not go anywhere near him
oh and there's gonna be snipers
freaking thrall
oh there are so many monsters
SiC blank alright now what
we're supposed to try and get up to that
other we should let them loose we could
use chains yeah let's let him out
was a night up top oh I overshot it
or the night jump challenge
as long as they stay and chained up I'm
good writes down well I think eventually
he can hit him taking damage
you headshot him no it says destroy him
alright dude you can't headshot him oh
no it's his chest my keister
that's his chest oh well it's been
decided he can get out of his chains oh
and there's more things coming in
shooting [ __ ] out of head
oh my god he is made like beam front
chest is his weak spot freakin critical
oh good
now if he hits you with him it doesn't
seem to be in Jessica they don't attack
for too long the moment he stares at you
just dump into cover
and you just shoot him anywhere yeah
anywhere is fine but the middle is those
where you go get Chris there's like a
little square box Oh more guys coming
even tonight
watch out Oh God
I got the night
Oh
Oh
I'm running low on ammo yeah you just
got to look around where the eysie
killed
I'll buy that
EMM I got a coke and you revoke me yeah
you're right mind your night next to me
anta you okay oh my god I went through
crap I got surprised running away oh
yeah Eric stay alive they'll ever yeah a
night with a big story thing I got 15
seconds everything
that doesn't even look like a good
there's a wizard too now to wizard the
wizard is shooting it where I used to be
yeah they do that
oh good
and kill the wizard there is right the
Wizards right next to you guys I know
there's also a giant or wizards and
knights
Jesus oh there was a Shrieker in the
hallway where I was hiding I feel like I
don't even know where ether is where
like the longer you take the more shit's
gonna [ __ ] don't try to revive me
there's a wizard guarding me there's two
monsters guarding me
it also means they can't respond
come on shield so did all the methods
gone
not with your IV running solo now the
wizard isn't wasn't guarding my body
anymore oh good so we taken down the
wizard or giant haha one wizard down I
think we should joke to get those words
that's a bunch of stuff down there oh my
god what the hell is it ah trolls just
came out of nowhere
on shield
where'd that Wizard go here all up in my
[ __ ] girl
I got a critical hit on the wizard I'm
not sure he killed him or not I think
he's gone
we did not like that
all these guys taking a while
people who see we used to talk about the
spider but this guy guys much be flair
mother wizards on the other side yeah
oh oh there's two wizards sweet
Wizards of above you guys and Knights
really
there's wizards on the other side I
thought
oh you're right geez [ __ ]
and then when I have my back turn Fogle
all right one was er done
hopefully I got the other one did I get
the other one
we're still another wizard overbite
phogoth yeah that's where I try to get
married yes get marry now is a good time
to get married oh she just spawned
anyway oh god oh gosh
wizard damn robot Oh stay alive Mary I'm
in the middle of the floor so right next
to phogoth so the Knights are down there
too
I'm gonna deal with the big guy partying
maybe well I'm gonna at least get his
attention
all right I'm responding Roy vine oh no
I'm responding the home ain't go after
the living
Jesco the wizard I'm working on it so
there's like a thing that appears in the
doorway
oh there's two Knights up here there is
a bunch going to you guys right now go
the wizard in the middle [ __ ] I gotta
stay more fluid
RiverDogs I'm pretty close to you know
are you yeah right there with the knife
to keep focus attention yeah but they're
not around anymore
just do everything did he just do a slam
yeah he did
slam enjoy him
what happened to the Knights no I don't
know
oh good
trying on the little cord was so
dangerous to go out there
[ __ ] booking it
secondary am
yeah
[ __ ]
oh good
whoa yeah he's pissed he's golfing
Hodor [ __ ] needs to die I've
been shooting at it damn it I don't care
I live just kidding grenades are pretty
good on him oh really
yeah they just keep sucking his life
away my super my super did like five
hundred damage you can't so what you can
do is you can duck in and out yeah go
the other side now now put it just like
straight book it did it like the other
corner or yeah you could do that with
you he's dead
seung-ah's we're just trading aggro it's
good well you can do it yourself you
just have to like
this is not where you want to be though
against them
I've been his grill now you just need to
have cover so that you can kind of go
back and forth
oh just kidding he like got smarter
they're better you guys stop shooting
him yeah
oh geez you need to run up there for him
on point I just need to know where are
you
that's fine anywhere near I found second
question to Mary I'm on their side
oh I probably get in for that game
like so close though yeah your body
uh-huh
where the drop there is that's all
that's left
whatever this thing is oh oh my treasure
chest chest were down by the landing
news if you go towards thank you
I have 18 seconds to get there I got us
an insignia from it
Oh loot that ship Oh Jade rabbit
disinfect this way over here oh no I
just jumped really high Walker Walker
from getting it where are you take an we
go to Mars I don't think